hello and welcome to the very first
episode of lockdown math so in this
first lecture what I'm going to talk
with you guys about is the quadratic
formula and traditionally I think the
quadratic formula is one of the most
famously memorized things in high school
we almost all kind of have this song
that sings in our head related to it and
yet if you actually ask someone how
often do you expect you're going to be
using this in the real world I mean how
many people are going to give an answer
that's greater than zero to that
question now what I want to do is give
you guys a lesson regarding the
quadratic formula that's a little bit
different from the traditional approach
and the main thing I want to focus on is
connecting it to other common patterns
in math that are useful for general
problem solving now the tactic that I'm
going to talk through it's not the usual
completing the squares bit that some
people will learn in high school and
when you learn that you often think okay
in principle I could read arrive the
quadratic formula but frankly it's going
to be a bit of a pain what I will talk
about is somewhat similar to something
that poached and lo put out a couple
months ago
for those of you who don't know him he
has a YouTube channel but more than that
he's the coach of the u.s. IMO team he
has a company called X buy does a lot of
great math stuff so he talked about kind
of an alternate way that we could teach
the quadratic formula the way I'm going
to talk about it is a little bit
different from how he did but certainly
very similar in spirit again the upshot
that I want you guys to come away with
is the fact that you should connect this
to other common patterns in math so as
to make yourself a better problem solver
and that should be the main takeaway
lesson for you know this particular
topic
now these lectures in general I'm going
to be shooting for something roughly on
the order of an hour for each one of
them and the dynamic that I'm going for
is one where there's questions that I'm
asking the audience and then the
audience interacts with it in a very
well in a very live way now the thing
about live stuff though is sometimes it
doesn't go the way that you intended so
the general technology that we're going
to have for this is going to involve me
pulling up some kind of question like
for example right here the question is
asking kind of facetiously about your
relationship with the quadratic formula
and I even had this going over the intro
animation for you guys and then what you
see is this
mystics associated with what the answers
you know other people are entering our
and they'll kind of get overlaid we see
the bars at the moment all you see are
question marks we don't know what the
most common answer was but at some point
I can choose to grade that and then
we'll see except for the fact that it
looks like there's quite a few of you
guys and it's giving our servers a
little bit of trouble so we have a
couple people who are gonna be working
that on that in the background in the
meantime I'll just be asking the
questions
that are pushing us through the lesson
for future streams this will hopefully
be a much more dynamic situation where
as you answer kind of grading it and you
see how it's going for this particular
one who knows some magic might happen
halfway through but there's a lot of
excitement among you guys right now
which is awesome and I love that and
let's see if we can translate that into
some of the math itself so one of the
questions that I was gonna ask is how
many times do you expect to use the
quadratic formula and when we were doing
this a little bit earlier with a couple
people for sure the most common answer
was zero zero times is when I think I'll
use the quadratic formula outside of
school and a funny story about that I
actually was once giving this talk at
Pixar where I brought it up as this
example of something that we teach every
student and it's unclear why they're not
gonna use it and I should have known
better than to say this to a bunch of
engineers at Pixar because one of them
looked at me he was like oh ho I'll have
you know I actually use the quadratic
formula all the time his name was Tim
Babb and he very kindly sent over
basically a storyboard for a video
something I think he was pitching me on
and the basic idea he was talking
through an image that he created purely
with computer graphics I think this is
totally beautiful you would think that
this is a photograph of some reflective
billiard balls but this is entirely
computer graphics and the tactics used
behind this involve something called ray
tracing so the basic idea there is you
sort of imagine a camera shooting out a
bunch of rays through each pixel of your
screen and then depending on whether it
hits the sphere and how it hits the
sphere that tells you how to color each
pixel now part of that problem though is
to know hey if I'm shooting a ray in
some direction will it hit a given
sphere and so what you might do is
to find a certain vector you might
imagine an amount of time that the beam
of light is moving and then you can come
up with a graph for how close is that
ray to the sphere as a function of time
and in some cases if it passes through
the sphere you're going to have two
solutions there and once you work out
the math it turns out this is a
quadratic equation so what you need is a
systematic way to plug in these
solutions to a quadratic equation and it
needs to be programmatic it needs to be
some kind of formula because you're
doing this for every single pixel on the
screen you also need to be able to know
is it just glancing off of the sphere or
does it not go through it at all and
again all of that comes down to solving
a quadratic and this particular
engineered Pixar he did they loose
back-of-the-envelope calculation for me
that suggested the movie Coco probably
used the quadratic formula over a
trillion times just given how many
lights there are for every single frame
in that shot so in some very real sense
the quadratic formula is useful to the
point of being used a trillion times to
produce a movie nevertheless I don't
necessarily think that's representative
of most people's future and it could be
the case that the reason we teach people
this formula is because maybe they
happen to be that Pixar employee you
never know what's going to be useful but
I want to make the case again that we
can connect it to other patterns and
problem solving bits in math and the way
that I'm gonna go about this is to start
in a place that's frankly completely
unrelated to quadratics and quadratic
functions I just want to talk about some
mental math tricks yeah because I think
if you are thinking about arithmetic
something very basic something we do in
elementary school and you think about it
deeply enough some of the patterns that
you observe become relevant to stuff
that you're doing later on so for
example let's say I asked you to factor
the number 35 you know it's easy to see
that 5 goes into it and goes into it 7
times each of those is prime great we
know how to factor 35 now factoring is
kind of an annoying task the bigger the
numbers get especially if there's no
obvious small factors that go into it
because if I asked you hey let's factor
143 I mean how do you go about it I
think the way a lot of us think about it
is we initially think okay we know that
2 doesn't go into it because it's not
even 3 there's
nice divisibility check where you do one
plus four plus three and that sum in
this case is five plus three or eight is
not divisible by three so that's out
five we can see doesn't go into it seven
okay you have to think about that for a
moment but you might see that seven goes
into a hundred forty evenly because
that's twenty times seven okay so that's
right out and at this point you might be
annoyed with whoever was asking you the
question but if you go one step further
you might see okay 11 actually 11 does
go into it and it ends up being eleven
times thirteen I just love the fact that
right now people probably have no idea
what any of this has to do with the
quadratic formula but I assure you
highly related because what if I asked
you three thousand five hundred ninety
nine and this particular example isn't
randomly chosen by the way I was reading
this article about a Russian programmer
in an interview that he had I think he
was at Goldman Sachs and he was
describing kind of the intensity of that
interview environment now and in one of
them he just walks in the door hadn't
even met the person and the person just
shouts at him factor 3599 you know the
program is like alright and he actually
was able to spit out the factors
particularly quickly which is impressive
given the fact that if we imagine going
through all of the different primes you
know just to go into it now just three
go into it no five no you're gonna be
sitting there for quite a while so
clearly something different was
happening in his head and the question
is what well one thing you might notice
about the numbers that I've chosen here
is that 35 is awfully close to a square
it's actually just one less than six
squared and maybe it kind of makes sense
that its factors are each kind of close
to six you know five times seven it's
probably not going to equal six times
six but the fact that they're sub
similar sizes should be intuitive and as
it happens it's precisely one less and
something similar happens with the other
example I chose 143 is rather close to a
square number 144 in fact it's one less
and it's no coincidence that it's two
factors are hovering right around the
square root of that value one of them is
12 minus one and the other one is twelve
plus one so it kind of makes sense that
the product will be something around
twelve times twelve and so from this you
might make a guess that
maybe anytime that you have some number
that's one less than a perfect square
and this you know it's suspiciously
close to a very round seeming number
3,600 well what is 3,600 we recognize
the 36 as being six squared and a
hundred is 10 squared so that's 60 times
60 and maybe you think okay the guess if
it's going to follow the same pattern as
what we've seen above is that this would
be one less than 60 times one more than
60 but of course you don't just want a
pattern match let's see if there's a
nice reason that it's a true you can
work it out algebraically which we will
but as you guys know I love animation so
let's just see if there's a nice visual
way to understand this particular
property and if we're going to think
about this the natural place to turn is
to think about squares so let me just
pull up an image of a square and if we
want to say can i factor a number which
is one less than a square what I might
have us imagine doing is taking the
corner off of that square okay so let's
say it's X by X whatever X is in this
case it happens to be 6 but you want to
think a little bit more abstractly than
that I'm going to take that bottom right
corner get it out of here we don't want
it the question of factoring is to say
can I rearrange the quantity that
remains into some kind of rectangle and
in this case if I take that bottom row
slip it on up to the right what you can
see is it forms a rectangle one with a
side length X plus one and another with
a side length X minus one so this
general property holds quite well and I
think that's really cool right you see
this visually you see that it's this
neat mental arithmetic trick where
anytime you have some sort of square
number minus 1 you can factor that as X
plus 1 times X minus 1 but of course we
can go one step further than that if we
really want to it doesn't have to be one
sitting there if we go back to our
diagram what you might instead do is say
hey what if I chopped off a bigger
corner of that square what if I wasn't
taking x squared minus one I was taking
x squared minus y squared well I can
rearrange what remains into a rectangle
where it's X plus y on one side and the
next minus y on the other side now
that's the geometric way that you can
view it which I think gives a certain
satisfaction
and when we view it in terms of numbers
it gives us a reminder of how powerful
it is and yet somehow when we do this
algebraically the magic is a little bit
lost it's definitely easier to see and
that demonstrates the power of algebra
but if I just said X plus y times X
minus y actually know it let me change
the variable names there I don't like
X&Y because those don't necessarily have
the same meaning
what I might do is try to picture you
know let's picture the original two
numbers that we had is something that's
like 59 and 61 on a number line and I
want to think in terms of the midpoint M
and then the distance between em and
each of the other numbers so plus and
minus D in this case D is just 1 but in
principle it might be something more so
if I asked you multiply M minus T times
M plus T at this point is pretty
straightforward algebra the first terms
M times M we get M Squared next we have
negative D times M so that's minus DM
next we have M times plus D M S Plus D
and then negative D times D so minus d
squared and indeed what comes out is M
squared minus d squared and if you're
anything like me the first time you see
this in an algebra class it's just one
of a whole bunch of exercises that
you're doing like yeah okay I can expand
this one way I guess some terms cancel
out nicely but the more you think about
this the more intriguing it is because
any two numbers we can express you know
if I just take any numbers R and s I
could write that down as some midpoint
plus or minus a distance and what this
is telling us is to think about products
is always the same as thinking about a
difference of squares
which is weird because products can be
very chaotic if I just walk through the
number line and I don't know wait I say
look at 101 102 103 and I just say take
a look at all the numbers on the number
line and I want you to systematically
tell me can each one of them be broken
down as a product of two smaller whole
numbers well we know that what that's
asking is what are the primes because
only the primes can't be broken down
like that and yet evidently that's a
very similar question to say
when can I walk through those numbers
and say hey am i able to express you as
a difference of squares could I add a
square number to you to get another
square I that still feels hard but that
feels like a very different question to
me so I think if you were doing some
arithmetic and you had this in the back
of your mind that's a good pattern and
that's a pattern that's gonna come up
later in life for example let's say
later in life you find yourself wanting
to understand quadratic functions and so
here we're going to talk about the the
simpler version of the quadratic formula
which is really just refactoring the
original thing but I hope you see it's
much easier to actually solve a random
quadratic that's thrown at you if you're
going by if you're going by the method
that I want to show you right here so
what's the task anytime you have some
function that looks like ax squared plus
BX plus C okay for any numbers a B and C
so maybe that's something like 3x
squared minus 4x plus 5 and you want to
know when that equals 0 what are the two
roots now this is actually equivalent to
rescaling everything and I think it's a
good common pattern to rescaling where
I'm gonna divide everything by a so I
just want that first coefficient to be a
1 because that's way easier to work with
so I'm gonna call that x squared plus B
prime X plus C prime where B Prime and C
prime are just the rescaled versions
there and this is a different function
it is a different quadratic function but
the roots are going to be the same and
one way that you might see this is if
you just graph them so let's go over and
pull up our best friend of desmos right
so let's say I have some kind of
parabola in this case I've written it so
that one of the roots is going to be 2
and the other is 4 and then G of X here
is just the scaled version of the
expanded version of that it's exactly
the same graph but let's say I wanted to
scale that up and down all right so I
might take this and then I will multiply
it by some kind of constant what do you
guys want to call that constant C this
is the thing if I had the question
framework working right now I could just
ask you what do you want the constant to
be and we would see the statistics come
up with what people had but instead
maybe I'll throw in a slider and as I
change that the function changes it is a
different function
but the roots are still 2 & 4 okay so
solving for this rescaled version of the
quadratic is the same and I should kind
of make sense because s times 0 is
always going to be 0 so it doesn't
matter how much we scale it so going
back to 2 what we're working with here
the reason that I think it's much nicer
to make sure that that leading
coefficient is a 1 is because if we're
thinking of our quadratic in terms of
its roots and I say okay you know it's
going to intersect the x-axis at R and s
or maybe it does maybe it doesn't but
let's just write one that does like this
another way that I could express that
particular quadratic is as X minus R
times X minus s because if I plug in R
it's clear that we're going to get 0 and
if I plug in s again this term will also
cancel out to 0 so if I expand this
whatever R and s are there are the
unknowns I should get the same thing as
what we have up here and this is
generally useful this is not just for
the quadratic formula but a very good
relationship to have with polynomials is
to know how the roots correspond to the
coefficients especially in a
circumstance where that leading
coefficient is 1 and the whole
polynomials been kind of normalized in
that way and in this case if you just
expand it out what we'll get is x
squared minus R plus s times X because
we have this minus R times X and then x
times minus s and then the constant term
will be negative R times negative s so
that becomes a positive R times s okay
so what does this tell us this tells us
the first two of the three key facts
that are needed to be able to solve any
quadratic without really needing to
memorize all that much so the first key
fact is that this B value I'll call it B
prime just to remind ourselves that it's
after you've scaled things down is the
same as the negative sum of the two
roots okay and then similarly C prime is
going to be the product of those two
roots which is kind of cool because what
we have right here is you know it's an
it's an it's a system that feels like it
should have a
we have two equations and two unknowns
but it's not obvious how we would go
about solving it and every now and then
I think classes will have a unit in
factoring quadratics where they
basically tell you to just guess and
check so in some very fortunate
circumstances if you have something like
you know x squared let's see minus 7x
plus 12 basically say see if you can
guess and find two different numbers
that add up to be seven and that
multiply to be 12 and if you just kind
of sit back there and think you're like
okay can I find any two numbers that add
to 7 and multiply to 12
well factoring 12 we get 3 & 4 & 3 & 4
do add to 7 so yeah in that case you're
just totally luck out and you could
write this as X minus 3 and X minus 4
because those are the two roots and then
you typically move on from that chapter
and it's like well in most cases you
won't be able to just guess and check
and in any case what you're gonna look
for is a general formula anyway so hope
you had fun with that but it turns out
there's actually a systematic way to
take this puzzle of finding two numbers
that have a known sum and a known
product and figure out what they are and
the key comes down to thinking in terms
of not the two numbers themselves but
the mean of those two numbers and then
the distance between that mean and each
one of them and you can see where this
is going this is why we talked about
difference of squares because the third
key factor to come away with or to come
into it with I should maybe say is that
we could re-express that product as M
minus D times M plus T and you see where
I'm going right that means that the
product that we know
looks like M squared minus d squared so
just to give an example here it's often
much more helpful to have numbers let's
say that you were given a quadratic like
x squared I don't know
mmm let's do 6 even numbers we'll make
this easier for us and then 7 okay and
you were tasked with knowing when does
this equal 0 but I haven't told you how
to solve it yet but these three key
facts are going to be enough to just
basically walk yourself in to the answer
well what is what is M right because
we're going to ultimately express our
roots R and s as M plus or minus D for
some kind of midpoint
well that midpoint is the sum of the two
numbers over two that's how we define
averages and because we know the sum of
the two numbers is negative B prime
that's the same as negative B prime over
two which you can basically read off of
the equation as just negative one-half
times whatever sitting right there which
in this case will be negative three
awesome we know what M is but look at
the equation we have up here we have an
expression for C the last coefficient in
terms of M which we now know and D which
is the only thing we don't know left so
we could rearrange this and so that was
saying C prime is that we could say that
d squared the square of this kind of
standard deviation between our roots is
M squared minus C prime the product of
the two roots but we know both of those
values we could just write that down
over here maybe I'll change colors again
be a little flamboyant d squared is
equal to M Squared which in our example
turns out to be 9 minus C prime which is
that last coefficient or 7 well 7
handwriting is terrible
but I think you guys can work with me
you see why I usually animate stuff so
that means that's 2 so look when we said
R and s is some midpoint plus or minus a
distance that midpoint is negative 3
plus or minus
well if d squared is 2 that means D is
the square root of 2 there you go you
could do that for any quadratic that I
give you you could just walk through
that particular process and let me just
show you what it looks like in general
so that you can maybe remember it as a
formula if you wanted to in general for
any quadratic that midpoint is just the
rescaled version of b if the leading
coefficient wasn't already 1/2 and then
that distance well what did we just do
we took the square root of the midpoint
squared
is the product of the two and when I'm
sort of singing it in my head I've been
saying like N squared minus P just
because P has a readable meaning I think
of it as the midpoint squared minus the
product but of course P in this context
is just whatever the last coefficient of
our quadratic was so over in this
example the product of the two
coefficients was seven so for me what I
think the simpler quadratic formula is
if you're going to memorize anything is
to come away and say it's M plus or
minus the square root of M squared minus
P all you have to do is first find M
which is you know just a factor times
one of the coefficients you're looking
at and then find P which is also if not
already a factor a coefficient that
you're looking at a rescaling of one of
them so this to me is way simpler than
the traditional quadratic formula and if
you were to try to sing a song to
yourself for the song is almost too
short it's no fun you're just sitting
there like mmm plus or minus square root
of M squared minus P that's it no song
no song to be had so let's do a couple
practice problems because I do think
practice will make it easier and for
future streams again it'll ultimately be
the case that I'm giving you these
questions and then you'll be able to go
to 3 B 1 B Co /live and answer them but
because there's too many of you we can't
have any fun today
this is the equivalent of trying to run
a class where you have you know I don't
know 20 seats sitting out and you're
gonna do a normal lecture and then
there's just people banging at the doors
and trying to cram themselves in and the
fire marshal comes in and they're like
ah you got to cut out the class you
can't have this the way that you hoped
for but it's cool that there's so many
of you here enthusiastic to learn about
math so let's just do some examples okay
that'll kind of highlight what this
process looks like let's say we had x
squared plus 10 X plus 3 so in this case
it's nicely already rescaled for us
that's always lovely so I often I just
like to draw the picture for myself
whether or not the two roots turn out to
be real or even positive it's just nice
to remind myself what we're looking for
we're looking for where the two roots
are and I know that a different way to
think about products is to think about a
difference of squares so I just kind of
think in my head okay I'll be thinking
of that in terms of their mean and the
kind of standard deviation so I just
write down for myself what does that
mean
well it's negative be prime over two and
if I forget that fact if I forget that
that's what the the sum of the two
routes is I could always just go through
this little rigmarole again and say okay
if I systematically wanted it to be a
quadratic with roots R and s this is
what it would look like this is how I
would expand so you can read arrive it
on the fly there's not too much
memorization needed in this context that
works out to be negative five and by the
way if I do ever make any mistakes which
I'm quite positive I will go ahead and
throw them in the chat and those will be
forwarded to me and I'll be able to
correct myself there so we know the
midpoint and then we just ask ourselves
what's the square of the distance and
based on difference of squares that'll
be that midpoint squared minus the
product which in this context is
negative five squared or 25 minus the
product which is that last coefficient
minus three so what are the roots R and
s well it's negative 5 plus or minus the
square root of 25 minus 3 or 22 there
you go
another quadratic solved ain't no thing
let's try another just because I do
think it's kind of nice to get a little
bit of practice here and as I'm going if
you have a piece of paper and pencil
please follow along if you can just kind
of race ahead and do the same process
before I do it that's awesome that is
the best kind of learning experience if
you're watching this in the future by
the way as with any video I highly
encourage you to pause and ponder I
really think that's the best way to
learn math if you're looking at some
kind of lecture in those crucial moments
where there's a question asked pause see
if you can do it yourself and then see
what the answer turns out to be I
guarantee you'll learn more effectively
that way I don't know what should we do
let's do maybe 3x squared I think I
wrote one down earlier didn't I just as
kind of a hop handed thing what did I
write that wasn't there
oh yeah was at the top let's do that one
3x squared minus 4x plus 5y not 3x
squared minus 4x plus 5 all right so in
this case step one we've got to rescale
things that's what gives
coefficients a nice readable meaning -
4/3 x + 5/3 great and now same process
I'm sort of thinking in my head of this
particular image where I want to know
the midpoint in the distance so I say
that midpoint is negative of this second
coefficient divided by 2 so that will
become positive 4/3
but then that 4 divided by 2 gives us a
2 so that midpoint will be 2/3 and then
the distance squared is M Squared minus
the product which in this case is 5/3
okay an M Squared in this case is let's
see 2/3 squared minus 5/3 all right so
this one you know gets a little Messier
we've got a work out our fractions but
that's not too bad 2/3 squared is going
to be 4/9 I'm off screen a little and
then what is 5/3 in terms of Knights
that's going to be 15 ninths if I'm not
wrong so we end up getting a negative
number which is always fun so here we
have negative 11 9th okay so what that
means is that our final answer the roots
of this polynomial R and s the values
that will make the polynomial 0 are
going to be 2/3 plus or minus the square
root of negative 11 over D negative 11
over d d what am I saying negative 11
over 9 okay so that's fun
in this case the square root is a
negative so that means we have complex
roots and there's actually a very fun
way to think about the way that complex
roots play into this difference of
squares perspective on the quadratic
formula let me actually try it with a
simpler example but it ends up relating
to the Pythagorean theorem which I think
is cool because the whole purpose of
this is to try to connect various
patterns in math that come up a lot
things that might be useful outside of
this particular class that you're doing
so I actually have written down for
myself an example that will work out
with nice numbers here
I mean nice-ish x squared minus 6x plus
10
okay so we go through the same rigmarole
we say M the midpoint is going to be
negative B prime over two so in that
case it works out to just be three
because we take the negative of this
term and divide by two d squared is
going to be M squared so three squared
is nine minus the product which in this
case is ten so nicely that's exactly
negative one which means that our two
roots I'm down down to the wire on the
page that I've been writing with here
our two roots are three plus or minus I
okay so what that means for us is that
the actual parabola here it doesn't look
like something that crosses the x-axis
instead it would be something that maybe
sits above it but it does have imaginary
roots so if we were to look at the input
space not just in terms of the real
number line but let me draw it out let
me go back to black black will be our
complex plane color for this moment
we'll call this our imaginary axis where
numbers like I and negative I the square
root of one or maybe I should say square
roots of one it's got two of them you
know change them it's fine
and then we've got just the real numbers
one two three four so in this case our
two roots live at three plus I and 3
minus I so this I should be very clear
this is not an x-axis and a y-axis this
entire plane now is where the input
lives where X lives if you were going to
graph it you'd get some kind of graph
that's outside of the paper and any of
you have watched the channel welsh labs
which if you haven't you absolutely
should might be bringing to mind right
now and absolutely awesome like
artificial reality effect he does where
he sort of pulls out that graph highly
worth watching super great moment but
what's interesting about this is if we
look at the magnitude of the roots okay
because I could ask you what is the
magnitude of that root and it's a right
triangle that we're looking at we've
switched from algebra to geometry now
and based on the Pythagorean theorem
it'll be the square root of one of the
lengths squared which is in this case
three squared plus the other length
squared which is 1 squared
so square root of three squared plus one
squared and that ends up being root ten
it is not a coincidence at all that the
magnitude of our roots I guess sort of
no pun intended the magnitude of the
roots of our quadratic equation here are
the square root of that constant
coefficient because remember that
constant coefficient is telling us what
is the product of the two roots and if
you know something about complex numbers
you might know that if I have two
complex numbers and I multiply them
together
the magnitude of the product is the same
as the product of the magnitudes so in
this case given that I'm gonna have to
separate roots who are symmetric you
know it's going to be three plus or
minus some imaginary number each of them
is going to have the same magnitude the
product of their magnitudes needs to be
ten
we know that offhand so you kind of know
ahead of time that it should be
magnitude of square root of ten and the
reason that this is happening is
basically because when you do difference
of squares
something like M plus D times M minus D
but that distance is an imaginary value
I what you get is M squared minus I
times d squared but because I squared is
by definition negative one you get a sum
of squares so even sums of squares which
come up in geometry Pythagorean theorem
stuff all of that can be expressed as a
kind of difference of squares which
itself gives a kind of factoring and
this this shows up in a lot of very very
beautiful math later down the road one
of my favorite videos that I've made
actually is Oh what did I title it
I think pie hiding in prime regularities
where you're counting lattice points
inside a circle and the key insight
associated with doing that is to realize
that asking when you can express
something as the sum of two squares is a
sort of factoring problem but it's
factoring not where you're dealing with
prime numbers on the real number line
but Prime's in complex numbers these
things called Gaussian Prime's so even
simple
I shouldn't say simple stuff but even
stuff that comes up in high school like
the quadratic formula I think if you're
learning it the right way it ends up
connecting to all sorts of other
delightful
things and remembering these patterns
comes up like I said so just to
re-emphasize how did we get here what
three key facts do you need to be aware
of with quadratics to be able to kind of
rediscover a kind of quadratic formula
on the fly the first one is how to read
the Contin the coefficient sitting in
front of X and if we have a quadratic
that looks like x squared plus B prime X
plus C prime you can read that first
coefficient as the negative sum of the
roots you don't know that already you
can rediscover it on the fly but that is
actually worth coming away with similar
with how we can read the other
coefficient it's the product of the
roots then the only other thing you need
to know is that we could express that
product of roots as a difference of
squares with respect to the mean and the
kind of standard deviation of those
roots and you can just solve any
quadratic that comes to you on the fly
the only thing that looks remotely like
memorization is if you want to jump
start to the end and just say M plus or
minus M squared minus P now to finish
things off I think it would be very
satisfying to remind ourselves that this
is actually equivalent to the
traditional quadratic formula something
that looks much bigger so let's go ahead
and let's go ahead and actually do that
exercise and again if you can pause and
just work it out for yourself right now
all right so let's remind ourselves of
how that goes so we've got what are we
solving any kind of quadratic ax squared
plus BX plus C we want to say no matter
what a B and C are give me a systematic
way to find these roots again maybe
you're doing something beautiful like
ray tracing let me pull up that image
again that was a really nice image I
just can't believe that this is
something that a computer generated I
guess I should believe it because like
Pixar movies are amazing but evidently
if you know the kind of math that can
lead you to create an image like this
one that's the kind of thing that can
get you a job as an engineer at Pixar
and of course what is that math that
math is exactly what we're doing right
now so let's work it out again ax
squared plus BX plus C equals 0 this
time we're just going to write
everything in terms of a B and C no new
variables coming up so when when we do
the first step of rescaling we say x
squared is equal to B divided by a
times X + C / a we don't give it any new
names now we remember how our trick
works we sort of picture in our head hey
imagine this quadratic has some roots
let's call them R and s and we're trying
to find the midpoint and the standard
deviation and we can read off that that
midpoint is the negative of the second
term divided by two so in this case
that's going to be negative B over 2a
great and then that standard deviation
is going to be M squared minus the
product of the roots which in this case
looks like negative B over 2a squared -
and the product here is what that last
term is C divided by a C over a now
remember if you if you don't remember
this idea that oh that's what the
distance is just we derive it for
yourself on the fly just go and say okay
I remember that the product P is just
the product of my two roots which can be
expressed as M minus D and plus T okay
that's something I can write as M
squared minus d squared oh okay
that's what gives me an expression for d
squared in terms of M squared and P
don't feel like you have to just come in
and know it off the top of your head but
after you do it a couple times it it
sticks in your memory so that's M that's
D and the quadratic formula is just
telling us that the roots are M plus and
minus that standard deviation which in
this case looks like maybe I'll write it
out on two lines cuz this will be a lot
negative B actually not all right it on
one line for this one negative B plus or
minus I'm jumping to the original
quadratic formula a little bit too hard
engrained we'll go back to two lines
negative B divided by 2a divided by 2a
plus or minus the square root I wrote
this incorrectly know someone should
have corrected me this is what d squared
is equal to d squared is this whole
thing so D itself is the root of those
I'm sure lots of people were shouting
that in the live chat I don't have it
pulled up now but
to those of you who did much appreciated
so what we have here well it's going to
be the square of negative B over 2a
minus C over a minus C over a okay now
we just got to expand this thing which
is frankly not super fun but it'll
connect it to the original quadratic
formula to it for us so I can pull out
this 2a squared and I'm just gonna write
that as 1 over 4a x times negative B
squared negative B yeah negative B
squared and then I want to also pull out
1 over 4a I want to be able to say that
the last term also looks like 1 over 4a
times something and that's something to
make it equal to C over a would have to
cancel out the 4 it would have to cancel
out an extra a and then C sorry because
this is really 1 over 4a squared
let's see if I'd done this right yeah
because I pulled out the 2 a so that
should be 4 times a squared so over here
I have 4 times a squared I want that to
cancel to become C over a which it looks
like it does so that's awesome so I can
go over here negative B over 2a plus or
minus and if this feels tedious that's
kind of the point the whole quadratic
formula is more complicated than it
needs to be because we were just solving
any quadratic that was thrown at us
without having to do this but this is
what happens if you don't introduce any
new variable names on your way it's like
code that hasn't been refactored
properly okay so what can we do here we
can factor out the 1 over 4a squared and
because that's in a radical it's square
root will also be 1 over 2a and then
what sits inside is what remains the
well familiar at negative B squared
minus 4a ok and this this is starting to
look like the traditional form because
if we pull on to the numerator negative
B plus or minus square root of why am I
writing negative B squared yeah so this
is a negative B squared same as positive
B squared what should sit on the inside
here is b squared minus 4ac
for AC you can see how scatterbrained I
am when I'm just doing some arithmetic
at times it's okay we all forget a
variable or two here and there but I get
maybe that's why I actually care so much
about formulas having nice readable
meanings because I think this is a very
error-prone process for someone like me
if I'm just trying to work through with
a bunch of symbols that I don't
necessarily know how to read them I get
to the end result and it's hard for me
to say like oh yeah of course that's
what the answer is whereas if I look at
something like the simpler variant of
the quadratic formula and if I basically
refactor it and I'm saying okay does the
midpoint equal negative B over two I can
kind of fact-checked yeah that that
makes sense especially if you know a
little calculus those of you will be
able to look at that quadratic formula
and understand how to find the maximum
or minimal point so that's a thing that
gets reinforced with a better pattern
later on in your mathematical life
always a good sign that you're learning
things well I can ask myself if it makes
sense that the distance looks like this
again that that has a readable meaning
so when I'm looking at the simpler
version of the quadratic formula we have
M plus or minus a kind of square root of
the variance a kind of standard
deviation so it's a refactoring now I
titled this thing this is the simpler
version of the quadratic formula and I
think someone could rightfully complain
like is this actually simpler because
you know you've got a lot of steps
you've introduced new variables into it
now in addition to thinking of the three
coefficients a B and C you're telling me
I also have to think about like a new
term M and a distance between them but
for me math is very much about trying to
draw connections to other patterns and I
think things are much better remembered
if you have that web of connections in
your head rather than just isolated
cases and the whole lesson here if we
think about what's going on it's about
representing the same information in
different ways right because what the
quadratic formula is doing for us it's
saying can I go from my coefficients a B
and C and we can I get to the roots are
an S and we know that there's a very
easy way to go the other way around
because we can expand something like X
minus R and X minus s and really because
that
I can get scaled out it doesn't add any
information to the system there's really
as much information as two different
constants in there so one of these
directions is easy and one of these
directions is hard and this idea of
information that can be expressed in
separate ways and translation one
direction being easy one direction hard
that comes up all the time in math
that's a very useful thing to think
about and another useful thing to think
about is how sometimes going in that
harder direction will be better if you
go through some intermediate step in
this case rather than thinking of your
pair of numbers on the number line just
as they are doing your m plus or minus D
trick because we know that that changes
how you think about products if you go
through the intermediate step of
expressing that same information with a
mean and a standard deviation that can
get you to the roots and that's all this
is it's just talking about different
information flow paths they can help go
between various ways to just express two
numbers whether those two numbers are
the coefficients of your quadratic are
the roots of the quadratic are the mean
and standard deviation so if the lesson
you come away with is one of thinking oh
wow sometimes there's a lot of different
ways that I can represent my data and
some of them lend themselves to certain
kind of problem solving better than
others
well then that is the proper lesson to
have with the quadratic equation okay so
I think with that I'm going to call it
an end to lesson number one really want
to thank everyone who showed up for this
definitely a ton of fun next time we're
gonna have the live quizzing dynamic
where we're going to get stats up on the
screen so it's gonna be pretty cool I
think this is a very cool thing the two
former co-workers of mine put together
from Khan Academy but obviously this is
the first time that we're trying it it's
a little rough around the edges so in
the end what it's going to look like is
these bars that you're seeing live oh
interesting these are bigger numbers
than they were before
okay clearly so they're updating they're
updating all this is exciting
do I have actual access here oh it would
be so fun to do this properly before we
end oh my god oh this is so great I
think we're I think we can do it okay
are you ready for this guys okay I'm
grading the answers Oh Oh wonderful Oh
we can see what people answered this is
great this is how I wanted to end the
stream while I was talking just in the
background some magic was
done this is wonderful so it looks like
the most common answer what's our
question here what best describes your
relationship with the quadratic formula
and the most common answer is C I'm a
big fan you might say I'm rooting for it
so it looks like 1724 of you 5 short of
Ramanujan's constant are addicted to
puns let's do a couple more this is
going to be pretty fun these were just
like the joke warm-up questions before
we got into the real lesson but I
actually think this is the perfect way
to end the whole lesson is to just kind
of wind down with some of what we're
meant to be introductory jokes oh it's
working I love this so much oh and
there's so many of you answering this
makes me so happy all right so what's
our question here if the quadratic
formula had a Patronus what would it be
okay well it looks like around 800 of
you I think it will be something but by
the way I am
I definitely being told right now that
if there's too many of you who access it
we're for sure gonna break the system
and I'm purposefully ignoring that
because I'm having fun with this and if
it breaks that kind of tickles me so I'm
being told not to say this but please go
to 3 B 1 B Coast live and enter
questions to this and then you know when
everything's break that would be a
perfect time to industry because I just
think that's hilarious
okay so again 1917 91 oh I guess we blew
past from when you gents constant maybe
I can I can try to see if I can grade
this at a point right where we're going
to lock in answers where the majority is
17:29 I think that would be fun okay so
it looks like a majority of people went
with C if the quadratic formula had a
Patronus it would be an old man hunched
over a chess board which is the correct
answer
actually you know this this question was
structured as a poll where there's no
correct or incorrect rating but I don't
think that's right I think it should
have been structured where C is the
objectively correct
JK Rowling would agree style answer all
right let's do the the warm-up question
number three here oh this is a fun one
okay
what does it say
what integer will most people enter into
this box
okay Oh lots of interest coming in again
I really want my friends to like
struggling bars all over my face you
know this actually seems apropos given
that the whole title of this is lockdown
math that it starts to look like I'm
slowly being imprisoned by everyone's
answers and just getting locked down
further and further into the quarantine
situation so this one actually now there
isn't where do i type help bars are
attacking me okay there's an objectively
correct answer because there is going to
be some number that most people enter
and it looks like 919 of you think that
it'll be one particular thing but we got
a wide spread this is actually pretty
fun so again if you want to partake in
this head on over to 3 B 1 B Co slash
live I actually think the best way that
you can do this
what is the 7 wow I would not have
guessed that most people entered 7 and
in a weird way like the plurality of you
are definitionally correct that 7 was
the most commonly entered expression 69
being the second most common I think I
can make a guess for why that might be
the case did you know that 69 is the
first number where if you square it and
then you cube it those two values
between them encounter the numbers or
the digits 0 through 9 once and only
once oh yeah it's the first number with
that property which I assume is wise
that was the second most popular answer
but the very end which is actually
apropos at this point we can pull up
another question which is going to be
what I was going to open the whole
lesson with so you can kind of see how
the plan went here how many times do you
expect to use the quadratic formula in
your real life outside of school and in
this case luckily I'm getting a little
bit less you know locked down by the
bars trapping me in here because it
seems like there's a little bit more
consensus around how many times people
think they will need to use the
quadratic formula in the real life what
I could do is a plot twist on this and
say you know interpret this question in
light of the lesson rather than when
will you literally use negative B plus
or minus square
root of I always forget a square root of
b squared minus 4ac over 2a 2a that
whole thing - when are you going to use
the principles of recognizing that a
product of numbers expressed as a
difference of squares can help you solve
problems or we can when are you going to
use the principles of expressing your
data in terms of a mean and a standard
deviation it can help you solve problems
that I think would give you wildly
different answers but at the moment
we've got a lot of you on the system and
it's not breaking I'm so happy right now
I just can't tell you how much this
tickles me so it looks like we've got a
wide forming consensus you know for for
my sake
can we can we just like keep going on
this I would love to see if we can get
that top bar up to 1729 whatever it
might be we can all guess what it might
be but let's see if you can go to 3 B 1
B Coast live wherever you're watching
this I think honestly the best dynamic
that I could imagine is if you just pull
up your phone and you're watching this
on a screen with the one hand and then
you're using your phone to to answer
questions a lot of you are already
watching it on your phone so that
wouldn't necessarily work but that is
the dynamic I would I would most expect
okay so I'm just gonna wait until we get
that top bar up to be Romani John's
constant of 17 29 for those of you who
don't know the famous story behind that
number is that I think it was the
mathematician Hardy was visiting ram
anujan when he was in the hospital and
he said I found this taxicab that I was
following on my way here and the number
on it was 179 and I thought to myself
what a wholly unremarkable integer
there's nothing special about it you
know it's not a square or PI or cube or
anything like that well we're getting
close so let me not let me not mess this
up oh I over blew it okay you know and
so he tells this to ramanuja he says
1729 has no remarkable properties and
Raman Newton says oh but can't you see
17:29 is the first number that can be
expressed as the sum of two cubes in two
separate waste he says I don't
understand how you can't see it Hardy
because 1729 is on the one hand twelve
cubed plus one cubed but on the other
hand it
ten cubed plus nine cubed and it is the
first natural number that has this
property that you can express it as the
sum of two cubes in two separate ways
and that's just such a delightfully
random fact that I think it became
immortalized in the history of math so
it looks like 1769 of you which is
appropriate given the second question
second most common entry here said that
you thought you would use the quadratic
formula zero times
and honestly I agree with you I don't
think you're ever going to use the
quadratic formula unless you're a Pixar
engineer in its actual form but I think
you will use some of the other lessons
that I tried to get across here so with
that I think that is the perfect time to
call things and end here really
appreciate you guys joining on this
first stream the next lesson is probably
but don't hold me to it gonna be about
how to not memorize trig formulas some
of the things like cosine of two theta
sine of three theta all of those things
and it'll be on Tuesday at the same time
unless something changes and you can
check the banner of the channel about
that and then for those of you watching
in the future hopefully this is just a
long playlist of high school lectures
that you can join and appreciate so
thank you so much for joining I hope you
see you next time and keep loving math